comment faire quand on est un chômeur de
longue durée qu'on a plus un centime sur
son compte en banque
c'est sur cette g que s'inscrit la pièce
écrite et mise en scène par francis
veber dans l'europe principal est joué
par gérard jugnot françois fillon
maurice pelouse inspecteur des impôts le
chômage depuis deux ans je suis bien sûr
si vous tenez à contrôler voire c'est
une pièce moral sur l'argent sur les
femmes sur une pièce le misanthrope un
petit peu un peu misogyne parfois comme
beaucoup de théâtre mais c'est surtout
une pièce moral sur l'argent et et la
folie de l'argent fou cet argent énorme
qui qui fait que des gens de change de
comportement et deviennent dingues sur
les traits être l avoir quoi cher trésor
où l'histoire absurde d'un homme seul
wynn et qui ne trouve comme seul
échappatoire que la venue d'un
contrôleur fiscal dans sa vie suis dans
la merde
ces personnes vous pourrez que l'on
comprend que je vais plus important ce
n'est pas d'être riche que les autres
croire hisse donc pièce assez c'est
drôle gens tous parce qu'il n'a plus
c'est d'abord et s est très bien écrite
elle beaucoup de rebondissements
le dernier acte les grands mots font
mieux et puis tous les personnages sont
bien écrits à cette drôle
non bien sûr moi je tire les wagons mais
tous les rôles ont des choses vraiment à
défendre et des effets des rôles de
femmes sont très bien écrits même si peu
cynique mais c'est vraiment très très
bien foutu et et la pièce on la joue
puis non parce que 500 fois dont on peut
dire qu'elle a fait ses preuves
gérard jugnot campisi françois pignon un
rôle taillé pour l'acteur qui trouve ici
une dimension familière monsieur pignon
pourrait être notre voisin tout
simplement un membre de notre famille en
reflet de la société avec ses problèmes
et ses désarrois quand on aime quelqu'un
comment s'est vu être aux flics ont
surtout à quoi des études aussi longue
mais bon c'est sûr on est au cinquième
on se retrouve en bas j'arriverai
souvent dont il est co et à françois
pignon d'ambert derrière fabien donc
c'est un personnage comme ça qu'ils
naviguent de pièce en pièce et dans cet
épisode là c'est un petit bonhomme comme
d'habitude c'est pas tout à fait le même
à chaque fois enfin là il est il appelle
au chômage sa femme l'a quitté vannes et
pas très brillant et pour exister à
cette idée saugrenue de demander un
contrôle fiscal
alors qu'il a parlé d'un seul coup tout
le tout le monde va pas tourner ça se
modifier autour de lui va s'apercevoir
que l'univers et à l'humanité n'est pas
tout à fait aussi rose que pense m
gérard jugnot aime explorer les publics
et venir à la réunion pour y jouer sa
pièce dans un décor similaire ou presque
fait partie de ce challenge on l'emmène
à la réunion et après à mort et c'est
assez c'est drôle parce que d'abord le
décor c'est pas une autre décor ils
adhérent construire il ya des choses qui
viennent un peul de paris mais d'autres
ont été entièrement refaites ici est
plutôt très bien après la réunion la
pièce a été jouée à l'île maurice cher
trésor et toute une fantaisie qui
convient gérard jugnot du rire mais pas
n'importe quel rire arrière pu dit
empreint de fonder sur des faits pour ça
même avec un milliard je ne serai pas un
homme riche jeu sera pauvre qu'à
l'argent